you can't fault Democrats for trying
even though now Donald Trump and
everyone around him has been shifting
from release the report it'll be great
for us to maybe don't release it because
it's not going to be quite so great for
us Democrats in the house are doing what
they can to get an unredacted version of
the report and the House Judiciary
Committee has authorized the approval of
Supriya of subpoena power to try to
force the Justice Department to give him
the report this is a really big deal but
it's also I don't want to overstate it
it's important to understand this is no
guarantee that Democrats in the house
are actually going to get that
unredacted version of the report what
the House committee has done so far is
authorized the chairman congressman
Jerry Nadler to use a subpoena to get
the report if he wants to and maybe it
won't be needed okay chairman Nagler is
saying he's first going to give William
Barr the opportunity to change his mind
and provide an unredacted report if he
doesn't then the authorization has
already been given to Nader to use the
subpoena power to try to get an
unredacted version of the report before
we even go into the analysis this is why
controlling the house matters this was a
party line vote in the House Committee
Democrats control the house meaning they
control the committee they had a
majority we might never get the full
report even with Democrats controlling
the house you can be sure that if
Democrats did not control the house we
would have no chance of getting this
report in close to an unredacted form so
that's a big deal now it's not making as
many headlines but also important and
approved are subpoenas for five former
White House staffers that Democrats want
to talk to you this includes Steven
Bannon the Trump propagandist this
includes Trump's old White House lawyer
Don Magan it includes one of trumps
former White House communications
directors hope Hicks
it includes Reince Priebus and one other
person that could be really interesting
we're going to be following when they
might show up and testify and in
addition to that congressman Richard
Neal friend of the show I've known
Richard Neal for a long time he used to
be my congressman and he's
been on the program before he is using a
very specific method that tax-related
committees have to request financial
documents directly from the Treasury and
he has done so with some number of years
of Donald Trump's tax returns whether
the Treasury will turn them over we
don't know but this is why it matters
that Democrats controlled the house the
to go back to the report briefly there
is a concern that the version remember
William Barr said he would give a
version of the report to the house there
are real concerns that the redactions
are going to be completely off the wall
bonkers because there is this category
that William bar said would be redacted
which is anything that quote would
unduly infringe on the personal privacy
and reputational interests of peripheral
third parties the reputational interests
of peripheral third parties that is so
absurdly broad and open to extreme
political manipulation that we have to
deal with that Democrats are saying we
will deal with it with subpoenas if we
need to and Republicans are going to do
exactly what we've predicted which is
drag this out as long as possible
they'll make the house wait as long as
possible to figure out what it is that
William bar will give them maybe it's
mid-april maybe mid-april turns into
later April or early May and let them
subpoena the report and eventually put
out something extraordinarily redacted
and fight the subpoenas themselves by
then it could be closer to 2020 which I
want to remind you is why we vote once
again if Democrats didn't control the
house there wouldn't even be the
possibility of a subpoena to get the
report since Republicans don't want it
and Republicans voted against it in the
committee which is reinforcing why what
matters most right now is voting in 2020
to get these people out will we get the
unredacted report or not tell me what
you think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show one of today's sponsor
is privacy calm slash Pakman this is a
free service that I've actually been
using myself for a while now and I love
it you just take a few seconds to link
your debit card or bank account to
privacy coms mobile app or browser
extension for Firefox and Chrome and
what that does is allow you to instantly
create virtual credit cards that are
linked to your bank account so that
you're not actually putting your real
debit card number on the internet and
you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5 towards your first purchase when
you sign up using that link below